there is another kind of made on the
board called stalemate stalemate is what
happens when your king is not in check
but you also have no other legal move on
the board and when this happens it's a
draw and nobody wins you might be
absolutely winning your game and about
to checkmate the opponent's king but if
you fall into stalemate it's a draw this
is best explained with some examples in
this position with white to move the
game would be a stalemate because whites
only piece the King does not have any
legal squares to move to and white is
not in check in this position let's say
white plays Queen to c2 the Queen gets
one square closer to the King but notice
blacks King is not in check and black
does not have a legal move in this
position the position is a stalemate
remember in chess you're never forced to
make an illegal move so black cannot put
the King onto a square where it would be
captured in this position can you find a
better move for white white can actually
win the game and just one move after
Queen B - checkmate
remember your opponent can never be in
stalemate if they are in check in this
position black looks doomed the king is
trapped in the corner white is ready to
deliver checkmate on the next move in
black is down lots of material however
chess is a game of many opportunities
even when things look really bad you
might still have a chance to save the
game or at least draw notice that since
blacks King does not have any legal
moves if blacks queen disappeared from
the board it would be a stalemate if it
were black to move in this position can
you find a way to make black's Queen
disappear and create a stalemate if you
found Queen 2h to check great job white
must deal with the check in the only way
to get out of the check is to capture
the black Queen now the only remaining
piece is the black King and since blacks
King does not have any legal squares and
black is not in check the game is a
stalemate what is saved by black let's
take a look at this position if white
played the move Queen to c7 it's not a
very wise move because white first of
all could have won the game immediately
with queen-to-be seven checkmate but
also Queen to see seven traps blacks
King but does that mean it's a stalemate
not in this position because notice
black has another piece black could play
the move h3 allowing white to correct
the mistake from the last move and
deliver checkmate with Queen to b7
notice if we added another pawn just
this pawn on h3 the position would now
be a stalemate with black to move now
that you've learned about stalemate
remember to stay alert and avoid it when
you're winning and when you're losing
keep your eyes open for the opportunity
to save the game with stalemate